the operations in speciality Steel's so
they're based in sites in South
Yorkshire I'm rather on stocks bridge
and brims worth there's a site in the
Midlands in Wednesbury and we have a
warehouse in we'll have a warehouse in
Bolton as well essentially we we take
scrap material recycled steel melt it
and then feed that steel into downstream
processes which converts it into a
highly engineered highly technical
products and they go into the automotive
aerospace oil and gas markets all these
operations profitable right now the
business is is doing reasonably well at
the moment it's moving into profit I
think the steel industry generally is
doing better than it was say twelve
months ago and we believe very strongly
that we can actually make these
businesses sustainably profitable so
what can you bring to them that Tata
were not doing previously well I think
the first thing is some we're removing a
degree of uncertainty that's been around
these businesses for some time but then
also we're bringing a significant and
maybe a more definitive vision for what
these businesses can achieve we have a
vision for the steel industry generally
called our green steel vision which we
and where we envisage recycling steel
that arises naturally in the UK melting
it in electric arc furnaces and
converting it into highly technical
highly engineered steels for for
downstream markets such as automotive
aerospace oil and gas etc now you
mentioned the sustainability of the
business there are 1700 people working
for these operations are they all going
to keep their jobs yes we again we this
decision today or this agreement today
to to acquire the business should remove
us a significant uncertainty that's been
hanging over this business we can we can
say that they the 1,700 jobs will be
secured and we'll look for opportunities
to grow this business in the future and
nothing is contingent on changes to
working conditions reductions in pay or
hours or reduction to pension benefits
anything like that no I did not I mean
we do and we intend to of course engage
we haven't had the chance thus far in
the process to engage with the employees
and the
unions will we look forward to doing
that and working with them letting them
understand what our business plans are
and how they can contribute to those
business plans going forward and you
mentioned just now that you have you
think you can make this business bigger
than it has been under Tata I mean what
sort of degree of expansion and we're
talking about here well I think we've
still got we've got to discuss those
business plans with with the with the
the management team in more detail and
and the employees but I think there are
some elements of the business that have
been reduced in previous years because
the demand has just simply not been
there and that we believe the demand is
coming back and we believe that we can
address our bit to change the business
model to enable us to access those
markets more readily so difficult to
quantify at this moment in time but over
the coming weeks as we discussed these
plans with with employees and other
stakeholders we'll be able to to explain
them in more detail and with whom were
you competing with these operations well
the nature of the products that we we're
producing here as I say they're very
highly engineered technical products so
we're not competing in a commodity
market the specialized market so we're
competing on technical capability of the
business and the people that we employ
in the businesses so we're not competing
with a wide range of commodity producers
existing in in the UK in Europe